Bobby Kennedy Jr alludes to his future
plans hi everybody I'm going to be in
Philadelphia on October 9th to make a
major announcement at the very
birthplace of our nation I'm not going
to tell you right now exactly what that
announcement will be I can say though
that if you've been waiting to come to
one of my public events this will be the
one to come to and I want to tell you
now what I've come to understand after 6
months of campaigning there is a path to
Victory there is a path to Victory path
Victory is going to be running third
party presumably that is presumably he
might surprise us but that is probably
what this announcement is